orléans 1969 une étrange rumeur se
répand à l'idée que des jeunes filles
disparaissent dans les cabines
d'essayage
[Musique]
nous sommes au mois d'avril 1969 dans la
préfecture d'orléans france
une étrange rumeur commence à se
répandre ce moment-là à l'effet que des
jeunes filles visite des boutiques de la
rue de bourgogne plus particulièrement
et disparaissent dans les cabines
d'essayage
la rumeur veut aussi qu'il ya des
preuves de dissimuler en dessous des
cabines d'essayage et que ce soit par
ses trappes qu'en petite n'a plus jeune
fille qu on les drogue et qu'on les
envoie ensuite outre-mer afin de les
prostituées la rumeur se répand comme
une traînée de poudre
moi même on me l'a raconté à moi j'ai
adoré plus les premiers jours on en a
parlé
je suis arrivé à la femme dynamique sa
belle-soeur les journaux s'empare
rapidement de la nouvelle aile c'est un
canular est véridique
on ne le sait pas est ce qu'on réalise
en fait au gré de l'anc est ce que la
plupart des boutiques ciblées sont tenus
par des propriétaires juifs
la nouvelle serait donc teinté
d'antisémitisme toute menue plus d'une
europe chez les juifs
la police décide de faire enquête mais
également une équipe de saussure roll
qui est menée à l'époque par edgar morin
pourquoi du sociologue parce que c'est
la grande époque des sciences humaines
et c'est peut-être le meilleur moyen de
comprendre un phénomène qui semble être
un phénomène de société
si vous avez une sur deux pages de
délires antisémites extrêmement
passagers et presque encore inconscient
la cadette regard marais a surtout
révélé qu'il s'agissait d'une part qui
étaient associées aux événements de mai
68 qu'elle ait eu lieu un an auparavant
une grande époque de révolution
politique sociale culturelle c'est aussi
la révolution sexuelle
et d'ailleurs pourquoi viser des jeunes
filles qui visitent des boutiques c'est
que c'est l'époque de l'achat des
minijupes et ça inquiète terriblement
les parents et pour eux c'est l'occasion
de dire à leurs enfants effrayés vous
voyez mes enfants faites attention
on commence par la mini jupe on ne sait
pas où ça peut conduire alors c'est
surtout l'enquète sociologique qui a
marqué l'imaginaire par rapport à cette
fausse nouvelle
elle démontre que l'on période de grands
changements lorsque les gens ont peur
ils ont tendance à croire davantage aux
fausses rumeurs
mais paraît que tout le monde en a parlé
mais j'ai couru pour moi d'agir que
chaque cours est